this is actually better than a lot of
Italian restaurants well in Japan they
do Hylian food better than the Italians
[Music]
[Music]
from instant noodle packets to
neighborhood noodle bars ramen has
become one of Japan's chief cultural
exports in the US last week I met with
Kaiser shimamoto and Sakura yagi for a
crash course in Japanese ramen styles
but today I'm interested in seeing how
ramen is blazing new trails in New York
City a lot of the time-tested techniques
to go along way like you learn from your
father you yeah my first stop is Miche
where chef Jack Nakamura is using
Muslimin a broth with style of ramen to
create an experimental form of Japanese
pasta
joining me is Frank Fenella mark Iacono
Carlo cartotto and Anthony Vitolo I'm
hoping some of my favorite Italian
American chefs can help me connect the
dots between ramen and red sauce ramen
shop poeta por hora de soie okay some
Theory new homes in Karen or a show
captain was taught about pepper de Soto
today behemot a cigar italiana a cheese
tapa tomato ha ha ha maan tapa so use
some of to arrive minutes captain a on a
super-sized Scarlett O Hara mindanao t
wanna do like a solid oak some lacquer
plans me the ball
the honey does for Nevada history no not
selectivity but somehow mushroom
sculpted stone a Shogun your pic quinoa
Tabata Neal take the Jane some chocolate
Chicago what should I put the June
singie Sarika oisika dog emotion coca
Mira it's never tear Kotoka do you know
smoker so no dander
die Jeannie staccato so no korekara Imam
Alhassan Shivan I meant to you some book
on each character even the Thomas K
Dodger korekara nominal Arabic is right
you
that's immaterial Mia Santa Sega Haruki
amante Sugino did I mean ano novo
sericata yukata okie Tomo ha de watashi
wa the toecutter seconds the octoroo
conundrum is an icon synagogue was
really correct
mera naam inconceivable small caps
technical things and I know toyou know
me Nowitzki really devastated a lot Oh
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me here
today at niche witches Jack Nakamura's
restaurant where he features massaman
which is a broth 'less type of ramen
chef Nakamoto considers this Japanese
pasta so I thought who better to enjoy
this with than York City's most beloved
italian-american chefs
enjoy I was told you are some annotation
that must precede you wait what do you
say in Japanese chef first dish I made
is a creme the bacon I made a sauce from
the double smoked homemade bacon mix
with a whole wheat noodle and they're
also Szechuan peppercorn from Japan with
Parmesan Reggiano and there's some pork
leg is it okay if I use a fork anoxic
you know I think it's totally funny
doesn't it make sense you just want to
make like Italian a state right exactly
because if you brought chopsticks Sidda
they would think that you use it as a
good match to light really good thank
you
have any of you ever tried broth less
ramen before never never
how about ramen everyone everyone gets
drunk lice and need something quick
okay you know after a night out on the
bar I've had brought this on the book
really how'd you like it I really enjoy
it I mean I love all types of like
Japanese noodles I think Bhutan is
probably my favorite yeah might be like
a bucatini we eat a lot of hookah tini
rest in Sicily plasticky sadly Wow yeah
a lot of sad I've been waiting a long
time for someone to a few
my two favorite cuisine yes favorites
Japanese and Italian if I was at a Thai
restaurant right now then you brought
this out to me like this I would have
thought that this was pasta carbonara
from maybe a different region Wow Italy
with a twist
I never thought you want to think and
again I would have never closed Japanese
this is actually very very nice this is
actually better than a lot of Italian
restaurants well in Japan they do
Italian food better than the italian
thats why i took this position the
community i said if they did you finish
40 today the other three dishes was
frozen law chili tomato and then you see
- bone brain Rosendo which is i that's
inspired from ross and daughters i
wanted to use a smoked salmon that's
possible the homemade mixed with cod
fish roe and also them use the summer
wall as well third dish was chili tomato
it was a bigger homemade tomato chili
sauce with topping of mushroom
cauliflower and broccoli and then the
last dish was used - boom brain right
like a Japanese dashi version of a bomb
wale that clam juice at the mix with
yuzu dashi and a little bit of money
from and also cabinets came on
you a question
yes sir because we'll familiy here
especially medium we have a Sicilian
origin Naples maple Naples
did you have a concept of mixing an
Italian green so this is just forward to
that ingredients came by coincidence
like that this is New York so yeah very
mixed culture of course I love it's a
base and also that my culture is
Japanese so I want to mix with us
something Japanese ingredients so I use
the ramen noodle which is a very
different of pasta it's a protein
content is a different more chewy more
sticker this is in the front of you able
to make anybody good is there a name for
this like you know this fusion yet I
don't think so that's like a British
[ __ ] don't like that
I think chefs been around a couple
places Italy yeah to me definitely use
the calibrator chili I've grown up going
especially my entire life my family's
from Italy we used to go through these
amazing restaurants this one restaurant
we went to which is a seafood restaurant
had all these pictures on the wall of
all these Japanese chefs that were
coming to the restaurant to learn from
one of the head chefs I still asking
that I was like is this a thing like
opening up Italian restaurants in Japan
and they're like absolutely you know
tons of Japanese students come to Europe
whether it's France Italy Spain and
learn you repeating food and then come
back to Japan and do it the research
that I found is that a lot of these
restaurants are just phenomenal the way
that Japanese culture is it's it's just
it's so specific and so they take so
much pride I think and everything they
do no shortcuts taking
and I think that that like lends itself
to really great cuisine if you're trying
to mimic Italian food I've been banging
my head against the wall trying like you
know come trying to play but again
to my favorite cuisine there it's a true
fusion of Italian and Asian chef nailed
it
yeah yeah you know he hit the nail on
the head if you're gonna take Japanese
food and try to combine it with Italian
food the most logical thing to do is
take away from and write and make
palaces with it they might give to eat
the lowness that's why yeah what do they
call Thai Americans at America's in an
entirely for eat fellow American
Japanese as Epona's I think it's eat
onus on the spot I'm confirming this as
eat alone as cuisine agree and accept it
i cheers to other chef good food and
good company
back at ramen shack kaizo is ready to
serve Sakura and I his crown jewel the
ramen burger keys who created the dish
as a link between la Burger culture and
Japanese festival food and the item
helped pave the way for a new Instagram
era of ramen innovation in the US
[Music]
I can't let you guys leave without
dessert this is my ramen burger so in
Japan they have sort of like a similar
thing at the festivals over there but
the way they make it is with the pork
chop growing up in California eating
burgers and ramen it was just naturally
that a burger would have beef and so I
put a beef patty and being between the
ramen buns and it just went crazy even
though the bun gets all the recognition
and I think the shorty sauce which takes
about six hours to make is really the
soul of this burger
it's messy
this is great they're holding shape
perfectly and it's not um you walk on
the night there's nothing like strange
about it you know
these noodles are also made fresh at my
factory you I can tell the same noodles
and for moments of the buns
it's really cute yeah yeah definitely
the ramen burger has inspired a lot of
different types of ramen dishes that are
no longer dependent on being in a bowl
I've heard of ramen pizza and a ramen
burrito what would you say is going like
too far
sameen I think as long as it tastes good
then it's it's not going too far
the ramen burger is actually not meant
to be a viral creation okay so even now
six years later you know we still see
long lines at Smorgasburg and I guess
you know I'm really good as she people
still enjoy it where do you feel like
the ramen scene is gonna go next I think
the ramen scene in America it still has
yet to boom they say that ramen boom in
Japan happened in the 90s but in America
even though ramen has become popular and
more shops are coming over it's still
like at that real beginning stage you
see all these ramen freaks online
Instagram there's a whole group of home
ramen cooks that do pop-ups every now
and then and like all these different
cities across the world and especially
in New York there's a young chef by the
name of Josh Reisner yeah Josh yeah it's
a cute little kid he's a lot taller now
but he was on MasterChef junior and he
really has a passion for ramen you know
I try to teach him whatever I can
he's always willing to learn he works in
other kitchens like fine dining as well
so he gets these ideas from fine dining
and then he takes my traditional
techniques and he starts to create his
own thing and I think that's the future
of ramen right there you know these
young kids that are becoming
professionals and really blending the
techniques and bringing it together to
create the
regional style
[Music]
my name is Jeff rassner I'm 16 years old
I'm a junior in high school and I am a
ramen chef I definitely have not eaten
as much as kaizo like 2015 I used to eat
like 300 bowls a year and when I went to
Japan it was like 30 and 21 days but
that was that was like the most it's
kind of interesting because I got into
the rum world as I was born I was born
when 2003 so that's maybe a year before
like Momofuku came in to New York and
then it was almost like a tradition
where my family and I like weekly or
monthly we'd go visit Momofuku Noodle
Bar I think there's a picture of me
eating at Momofuku in it like a stroller
when I finally turned 10 and I was like
into cooking like for real that's when
it was like oh I ate this growing up and
I really liked it
this is something that I should jump on
heizo humo moto Sakura yogi they've been
really great mentors to me I've just
have all this knowledge from all these
different places and I'm just trying to
figure out how to integrate it into
ramen I met kaizo in 2015 and I went up
to him I was like I know who you are
you're the guy who like flips the ramen
burger and I hear you make really good
ramen and he's like yeah you're like the
little chef boy and I'm like oh [ __ ] he
knows about me something that kids are
did very well was he balanced
experienced variety and finesse there
are places in New York that are like
good but they only have two or one out
of the three
whenever anyone would ask me Oh where's
the best run in New York I would always
say you could go to ramen Shack and you
could get the whole menu you won't be
bored at all it's the best place in New
York City
so I think the future of ramen involves
like that idea of true fusion where
ingredients are clearly connected and I
think if that starts anywhere it has to
in New York or people who studied in
different places and they go back to
Japan New York ramen is so unique
because people have already opened their
eyes to just so many cuisines you could
go to a different block and the food
just changes and that's just like ramen
like because chefs have grown up in New
York the way that they understand ramen
and nostalgia and culture is totally
different
[Music]
all right so thanks for coming in and
thank you for being my final customers
at ramen Shack so we're getting the last
bowls of your ramen here ever yes I'm
here to do more than just open a shop so
I think down the line you know I want to
do more for ramen I want to help other
people build shops I want to help other
people build a noodle business so I
think there's more opportunity for me to
help the ramen seen expand and I think
that's where the future for me is going
to be new adventure yeah so it was such
an honor honestly thank you so much I
miss you daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for watching goatee
gay guy so appreciate it Shaun should
they like and subscribe like and
subscribe or else thank you